yeah welcome to a new video and my Play
default against done a Russian player at
least he's got a Russian flag to 184
rated my own rating is also suffered
recently some really rather low usually
am I'm am somewhat higher rated but I'm
not in such a great little shape at the
moment I happened practice there's so
much and it really shows so on what line
well there's lots of choice here and
this Rubenstein rookie a rookie a
twosome a rare move okay let's just
continue to to develop yet it's not so
clear what this this rook moves us doing
sometimes that can be a preparation for
for Bishop back to f8 but this is not
really on and now just defy for right or
does the big idea oh it's going down
okay let's grab some some space in the
center don't like to give up the bishop
but okay not possible to do anything
else at the moment
one slide some issue with the black
setup is that it costs some time this
9065 d3 in the long run black is
certainly good here I am have some
weaknesses on the you farm I want to
play before really a 493 and then
somehow e5f possible of course them
normal now would be d6 just completing
development soon with the bishop move
yeah not much choice need to do that
yeah once a typical benoni problem here
this is sam benoni structure and the
typical problem is that this bishop on
g4 arm it was originally on c8 it's just
dumb i rather useless piece it doesn't
have from any natural square and sorry
hmm slightly sore throat it doesn't have
fun a really good square to go to and
with Bishop g4 sometimes you can
exchange it but this is why I instantly
played night to g3 to make sure that
this piece is not exchanged ok so he's
basically committing to retreat this to
d7 the question is do I have something
something good here ok I'll take this a
temporary it's a mostly useful anyway
yeah okay I cannot go to g4 or something
probably here ooh yeah probably here
yeah maybe I should have prepared this
better and yeah there should be 3 i'd
like to play but should be three but he
may be can take on c3 and then take the
five who yeah I need to get rook e1 n
and the books of our must be must be
involved a fun thing okay this is
somewhat weakening though yeah I can go
and it can get it can go back to f2 on
f2m covering E 4 and it's not a big
issue the queen is really am on the
wrong place that needs to switch back to
the kingside Queen do you want f3
something like that the only thing
really am helping here send that he's
spending a lots of time
yeah I probably didn't play this too
great but it's it shouldn't be a
shouldn't be bad for me question is how
to continue exactly it's not are not so
easy I want to get rid of this bishop
and probably a maybe lemme just go here
the bishop is simply strong okay so what
now lots of possibilities f5 Queen D for
a three okay let's insert this move v5
is also AM I'm a possibility nightly for
being the idea maybe this is too well to
open but the thing is he's planning
before I really want to go to e form
after the smooth but this is the kind of
move that can terribly backfire because
yeah exactly because of this my king is
serve is not exactly great here on h2
Queen f3m probably attacking f7
maybe for even I but they can take you
five instantly
he will probably get huge problems with
the clock but I still want to want to
make some some good moves come on this
shouldn't be bad I mean if I've is now
protected and I'm attacking the c5 rook
so maybe I've got the time to to play
just King King to g 1 i'll wait what
about rook f5 let's just quickly check
this look at five takes Queen g5 looks
good yeah but 97 I need to get the King
out of this diagonal it's really it's
really a necessary to do that and now
maybe here intending Knight b6 on 95 now
of course this is download time and he
needs to do this active move maybe
they're good i mean it's not not like
this is not possible
just here right 96 or not f6 if he now
takes yeah this is just two pawns and
maybe I had something better even but ok
this is it it is enough yeah complicated
game we're at some point I may be was
worse in the opening this looked this
looked a bit a bit slow I think like
sony has an advantage somehow here
Bishop c5 is an advantage from black
pretty big one Bishop c5 to deform it
looks good it was it was very
complicated and somehow I've rigged it
out of this and around yet so it starts
to get get tricky for black 24 was even
better here Jack when you form that
attacking c5 protecting a t5 this is
what i did now with queenie three and
yeah this is justice this is just a time
scramble yeah very interesting game I
think I was lucky that he spent so much
time yeah thanks for watching
you